Turns out that fake weed you can
buy has some very real dangers.
I know, shocker.
Hey, this is Annie for D News.
Even as medical
marijuana is legalized
in a growing number
of US states,
synthetic cannabis
continues to thrive
as a cheap and legal-ish
way to catch a buzz.
You might have seen these
around at head shops
or even gas stations,
under the names K2, Spice,
Black Mamba, Funky Green Stuff.
You'll know it when you see it.
Often marketed as
incense or potpourri
and labeled not for human
consumption, wink-wink.
Why do I say legal-ish?
Well, synthetic drugs
are hard to regulate
because their
compounds can be so
easily re-formulated to avoid
laws like the 2012 federal ban
on synthetic drugs,
which has not done much
to slow their production.
And synthetic cannabis
is actually a misnomer,
because it's not
cannabis at all.
This stuff is basically a
bunch of dried shredded plant
material with chemical
additives that
are supposed to produce a
cannabis-like high, elevated
mood, altered perception.
You know, high.
And among high
school seniors, it's
the second most popular way to
get there behind actual pot.
According to the National
Institute on Drug Abuse,
about 11% of the teens
surveyed had tried it.
And synthetic
cannabinoids have been
linked to thousands of
hospitalizations, including
60 in a single
weekend in Colorado.
Granted it was Labor Day weekend
and there was a Phish concert
happening, but still, 60.
But even beyond those
hysterical local news headlines,
the dangers of synthetic
drugs are increasingly
supported by medical research.
In a study published in
the Journal of Pediatrics,
the drug K2 was tied
to heart attacks
in the case of three
hospitalized teens in Texas
who had smoked it.
And this week, toxicologists
from the University of Arkansas
confirmed that
synthetic weed can
produce side effects like
seizures, hallucinations,
kidney damage, and
psychotic behavior
that can linger for
months in some cases.
But they also determined
that those side effects
can vary widely from
person to person.
In the meantime, I'm
not going to tell you
what to do with your
lives, but maybe
avoid smoking incense you
can buy at gas stations.
Just a thought.
Have you seen any of
these sold in stores
or heard any stories
about their effects?
Tell us your story
in the comments.
And as always,
thanks for tuning in.
See you next time.